[Music]
you started really well but then
something went wrong in this game with
we shook yeah basically I was playing a
bit too slowly from from the start and
it was only in the game with Chris shirt
that I I got punished for it and then
and then actually the next couple of
games were decent as well up to a
certain point but again I collapse in
time travel I mean that is maximum I
could just the one a piece at some point
I mean I was better and then at the end
I can do just yeah I was led back in the
game
wait and make it over 250 points but
then in this last round you got a bit of
Fortune yourself now I mean I mean
clearly the last couple games were just
garbage I mean I was exhausted and and
just hustling I mean the last game I
just didn't care about the cold at all
it was just about hustling and
fortunately I managed to as I understand
you use some some neck or back problems
and you got a special chair for it you
say something about it it's it's feeling
a bit better now perhaps because of the
adrenaline but some something just
happened yesterday after the games I
felt very very awkward but perhaps it
will stiffen up now after the games so
it's sad you know it's not a help but
I'm not going to blame that on on
anything yeah and of course yesterday it
is a interview with Maurice there was a
lot of talk about it
how do you look back at it because to me
it's in you you had a bit of a point
your game with bakra was pretty good
actually and at the same time you're
yeah you're actually your reaction was
quite fierce how do you look back at
this well it also had something to do
with I mean the way that we're talking
on the way in like
saying stuff like Rishikesh the
favorites and I mean he he he did well
enough but I think when you make seven
out of nine and undefeated I mean it
should be there should be some credit to
that and apart from the game with
karaoke I basically didn't have any bad
positions at all and whatever mistakes
I'm made were like quite hard to spot so
yeah I just felt that I mean it was the
angle was way too negative I mean
obviously always possible to stand there
and and say nothing but I was not in a
mood to do that so okay last question
still just one point ahead of Nakamura
my Moran's to go in the tournament where
everybody seems a little bit shaky how
do you see your chances for tomorrow
alright so it's really tough for the
time control with the delays uh
everybody's adjusting to it maybe I
don't know I don't know if people are I
mean the time scrambles are just
ridiculous so yeah I mean it up to a
certain point today I played I played
quite well but I think tomorrow just
have to play faster that's that's that's
the main thing and yeah obviously being
three points up earlier today being one
point up doesn't feel so great but still
plus three today it's not a disaster but
I'll have to probably do a sleep at
least as well to to win